[Music]
did you know the very first assembly of
photographs to create a motion picture
was a two second clip of a black man on
a horse
and that man is my
great great grandfather great there's
another great grandfather
but that's why back at the haywood ranch
as the only black owned horse trainers
in hollywood we like to say since the
moment pitches could move
yeah skin of the game
[Music]
uh
it's a bad miracle
they got word for that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you got your toothbrush
do you have your deodorant yeah do you
have your cozy clothes got that
what
do they know i'm black
should they you might wanna you know mom
and dad my black boyfriend will be
coming up this weekend i just don't want
you to be shocked that he's a black man
i ain't never seen you like this before
bro meeting families taking road trips
looking back all boozy man come back get
your hands up to your stomach
[Music]
[Applause]
so you guys coming up from the city yeah
we're just heading up for the weekend
can i see your license please he wasn't
driving i didn't ask who was driving i
asked to see his id
call me dean and you hug me my man so
how long has this been going on this
this thing
we hired georgina and walter to help
care for my parents
when they died i couldn't bear to let
them go
do you smoke in front of my daughter i'm
gonna quit she'd take care of that for
you how hypnosis
i'm good
actually are you ready for this
i'm back in the d
so look i go do my research
apparently a whole bunch of brothers
been missing in this suburb but it's
cool bro how you're not scared of this
man
couldn't see another brother around here
chris was just telling me how he felt
much more comfortable with my being here
you know sorry man get out yo
[Music]
we gotta go is everything okay
roast the keys
just get the keys i don't know where
they are rose
[Music]
sink into the floor wait wait wait
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
if there's too many white people are
getting nervous
no
no
no no
no no no no no no no
is a terrible thing to waste
[Music]
[Music]
it's about drugs it's not about drugs
it's a dope song don't do drugs get in
rhythm
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
can't believe how big they've got do you
hear gabe got a boat
he's kidding right he's not kidding hey
i think it's vodka clock oh yeah where's
jason
[Music]
jason jason where were you i didn't know
if you were lost stick with me and i'll
keep you safe
[Music]
there's a family in our driveway it's
probably the neighbors
which i'll scare a family
hi can i help you
zora
put your shoes on if you want to get
crazy
we can get crazy
[Applause]
they look exactly like us
they think like us
[Music]
they know where we are
we need to move and keep moving
they won't stop until they kill us
and we kill them
be careful
you shall pay
black prince
i press you with my name
you shall be
blacula
a black avenger
[Music]
rising from his tomb
to fill the night with horror
blacula
dracula's soul brother
deadlier even
[Music]
that ran in front of my cab you're the
only imbecile on this street
[Music]
[Applause]
he hungers for your soul
warm young bodies will feed his hunger
hot fresh blood will quench his awful
thirst
make it a bloody mary
are you um
into the occult
about the uh heavy stuff
what do you think of vampires
vampires
i think they're possibly the most
fascinating ball
[Music]
more horrifying than dracula
the black avenger
[Music]
from american international pictures
[Music]
you
better wake up
the world you live in is just a
sugar-coated topic there is another
world beneath it
the real world
for thousands of years
they have existed among us you keep your
eyes open they're everywhere chances are
you've seen him yourself and didn't know
it a secret nation
our livelihood depends on our ability to
blend in with the lust for power
we should be ruling the humans these
people are our food they've got their
claws into everything politics finance
real estate there's a war going on out
there he makes the weapons i use
now one will lead them to conquer
mankind tonight the age of man comes to
an end we're going to be gods
and one will try to stop him dead
the worst things out tonight than
vampires like what like me
half human blade's mother was attacked
by a vampire while she was pregnant half
immortal
you got the best of both worlds all our
strengths
none of our
weaknesses is their greatest fear
and our only hope let's open seasonal
vampires
you're one of them aren't you
no
on something else
blade
[Music]
who's there
[Music]
okay
you need breakfast i'm fine i wasn't
asking
nolan wright
involved in a car accident resulting in
the death of his wife is there anyone
else who can pick you up she's running a
little late today and severe memory loss
if this happens again we're gonna have
to notify child services i believe that
i can reverse your condition
we should give it a shot right
come with me please
we call this headset the black box
an immersive virtual pathway to your
memories
i like to begin with something i call
the safe room
when you push the crown on the watch you
will be in your subconscious are you
ready rachel
what the hell's in there it's your brain
trying to protect you from your trauma
did you go well with dr brooks today i
saw my wedding that's progress right
there if that thing shows up again you
just say to yourself i run my mind it
does not run me
i run my mind it doesn't hurt me
i run my mind
patients are often surprised by what
they remember
did rachel and i live in an apartment i
don't think so the place was really
familiar
you're getting close stay with this
did we ever fight it's not what you
think you would never hurt rachel
what's going on we're close like
consensus
you just need to remember who you are
i run my mind
it doesn't run me
[Music]
blood is red
voodoo
is blue
sugar
is sweet
but a brand new face my friends call me
sugar the foxiest looking for anything
special sexiest
deadliest chick in town
the mob took sugar's man away
and now
she's gonna make them pay
i want them dead
with a voodoo priestess called mamma
matress i know what you can do
the power you possess
how strong is your hate
and baron sandy too my particular
special a drink that i'm famous for
the zombie this is my domain
a kingdom
of the day
an army of undead behind her each death
has had something to do with
voodoo ritual there's nothing that sugar
can't do
use it
the mob has never seen anything like
sugar hill and her zombie hitmen
[Applause]
for centuries they have roamed the earth
fearsome creatures of the night
endlessly seeking to satisfy
an unyielding hunger
[Music]
now
the world's last vampire is about to
encounter
something infinitely more terrifying
than himself
brooklyn
interesting i've been stabbed
and i've been hanged
even broken on the rack once but i've
never been shot
it before of itches a little
paramount pictures presents
oh no if you're hungry i'll run you down
the kfc down the street hit you off with
a two-piece
i already had italian
[Music]
murphy do i look like i would buy it
angela bassett you bet not not after the
day i've had eddie murphy everything
come on move it yeah yeah right there's
a lot of love in this room look at this
and eddie murphy bottom line brother and
sister what i'm trying to tell you
tonight is that evil is good let me hear
y'all
[Music]
if he fails here oh quickest way to a
woman's heart
church it's actually through the rib
cage but that's a bit messy
being undead
you got the dropsies
won't be worth living
i'm a cop
if you uh try anything
i'll shoot you
women
vampire
in brooklyn
i would love
to have you
[Music]
for dinner
[Music]
can't wait to we're older you can leave
this place where do you want to go
somewhere where the sun's always shining
kevin
[Music]
kevin can you hear me it's me bobby
scared mommy me too okay but i'm not
gonna leave you
[Music]
bobby hide
[Music]
ah
[Music]
congratulations
you're being released as asylum seekers
not as citizens not yet
you will be sent to a home of our
choosing you must not move from this
address
we are good people
whether or not you're good people
it's not me that needs convincing
it's a palace
this entire house is just for us
it's gonna be nice you're gonna be happy
as long as you can get along fit in
be one of the good ones
[Music]
this is our
home well i can taste this matter
we'll get used to it
[Music]
i saw something
in the duck
you have felt it too
[Music]
we're having problems with the puppy
this is what they want they like to see
us crazy
let them send us back
how quickly you forget
everything we went through to get here
rats did this
you don't wonder what it tells me
it says i should be afraid of you
[Music]
you